well former secretary of state madeleine
albright is warning of a looming
worldwide political threat
during her career in public service
albright met with controversial
political figures including former north
korean dictator kim jong-il
albright argues in her new book fascism
a warning that contemporary leaders are
turning to the same tactics used by
fascists like hitler and mussolini
nearly a century ago
she writes quote we should be awake to
the assault on democratic values that
has gathered strength in many countries
abroad and that
is dividing america at home secretary
albright is joining us now with this uh
book which is so important and comes at
such a pivotal time
in our country and i would say the world
as well you talk about
your family escaping czechoslovakia when
the nazis invaded
only to escape once again once the
communists came to power
talk about any similarities that you see
now percolating
that obviously you went through and the
world went through uh nearly a century
ago
thank you all for having me and and
raising and letting me talk about this
issue um i grew i was born in 1937
and in 1938 an agreement was made called
the munich agreement
which appeased a dictator hitler
and i think that that's a lesson out of
that you have to understand what is
going on
and not give in to evil and then after
the war
when as a result of agreements made
during the war
europe was divided and the communists
quote liberated the red army liberated
czechoslovakia
and so you have to be aware of the kinds
of things that are going on
that these really are kind of one step
at a time and the thing that i'm warning
about
are the steps that are there that we
aren't
paying enough attention to and looking
at what the history
was of mussolini and hitler but also
looking at what's going on now in
countries in hungary where they just had
an election
in turkey uh in the philippines uh in
poland
and in venezuela are just the examples
that are happening now so you're talking
about relentless power grabs essentially
so who is doing the appeasement what can
the world do
well i think what we're doing is kind of
normalizing some of this and thinking
this is just a step
and what is really happening is that
there are uh
leaders that are reacting to something
that is happening
within societies people are not happy
that's for sure some as a result
of technology and they've lost their
jobs some as a result of immigrants
coming into their countries
and these leaders are grabbing power by
identifying themselves with one group
and then
with fear with fear and then also kind
of excluding the individual rights
of other people and being above the law
and undermining
democratic institutions so who's missing
the signals here
is it the american government american
senators the president
is it europe is it the populations where
who are the ones missing the signal i
think frankly everybody because
people do want some answers but i'm
particularly concerned about the
democratic institutions that are
the first article of our constitution is
about congress
and i want them to really understand
what's happening i want to read from
part of your book because i think you
hit that point you write if we think of
fascism as a wound from the past that
had almost healed
putting trump in the white house was
like ripping
off the bandage and picking at the scab
what has trump done well i think part of
the issue is here first of all he's
attacked the free press
which is central to having a democracy
he acts as though he's above the law
he has in fact used kind of rallies and
propaganda and
provided a lot of simplistic answers to
questions
and does not respect the rights of
others yesterday he called
from inside the cabinet room he called
the fbi raid on his personal
attorney an attack on our country well i
find that ridiculous and it's one of
those things where
as i said we can't have a leader that
feels that he is above the law
the law and the rule of law is the most
essential part
of a democratic system can i get your
take on some of the top foreign policy
challenges for this president
well let me just push back briefly on
that which is that republicans would say
look he won an election the american
people elected him
and what his critics will do is the
minute they he does something they don't
like
they say he's a fascist and that that
overstates the case i'm actually not
saying he's a fascist i'm saying
that there are certain elements of the
kinds of behavior that he has
that reminds me of a variety of issues
that have
taken place but i think that this is not
about just this election
this is about what is going on in our
society in terms of respect for
democratic principles
i think trump is the most undemocratic
president i have ever seen
in american history and so that's what
worries me but i do think that we all
need to pay attention
which is why i'm this is a warning
that's what the book is about
when it comes to the national security
of the united states
let's talk about that president trump
has set up what is appears to be is
going to be
uh a global summit or i should say a
summit
with the leader of north korea you've
been there what are the stakes there in
meeting one on one with kim jong-un
well the stakes are very high i'm
actually glad that there is some
desire to have diplomatic talks but i
did go there it took an
awful lot of preparation you don't just
kind of show up
we had been trying to figure out a
variety of things to do
about north korea the former secretary
of defense bill perry did a complete
review all kinds of things
so what worries me is the lack of
preparation
and a lack of understanding of the terms
should we believe kim jong-un said when
he says he's ready to denuclearize
well he says it but his meaning i think
of it is a little bit different than
what we think about
he thinks i think that it's going to be
done in phases
and what we need is to have verification
and complete denuclearization the
president has said
that a response is potentially imminent
to the chemical attacks in syria what
should that response from the u.s
look like and should regime change be on
the table at this point well i think
that what is needed is a strategy we
can't just kind of do one-off bombing
i do think we need i personally believe
that there should be some military
response to what just happened
but it needs to be within an overall
strategy that does i think require
a change uh assad is killing his own
people
and that is just uh it's a war crime and
he may stay it looks like well that's
the issue
and is russia complicit in that yes i
think there's no question
have two presidents in a row been
complicit in that by not taking a
stronger statement well i think that
what happened was president obama
did draw this red line he wanted to have
support from congress because he didn't
want to go outside the law
and then congress did not act i do you
know i think one of the problems about
drawing red lines
and deadlines it ends up being a problem
for yourself so i'm opposed to deadlines
on things
well secretary albright good to have you
here thank you so much
thank you so much and her new book
fascism a warning
is on sale now